ALL I GOT THIS IS AND SOME WATER
$177.
>> I'M A VEGETARIAN NOW BECAUSE
OF PRICE OF MEAT I CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD IT.
>> GAS STARTED GOING UP AND
GOING UP BUT PEOPLE'S PAYCHECK
AIN'T GOING UP.
>> UNTIL THEY ACTUALLY REALIZE
WHAT'S GOING ON OUT HERE, WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE SUFFERING LIKE
THIS.
>> Bill: ABOUT 300 MILLION
FEELING THE SAME WAY.
BRING IN OUR PANEL RIGHT NOW
SYNDICATED RADIO HOST HUGH
HEWITT WITH US TONIGHT.
MORGAN ORTAGUS FORMER STATE
DEPARTMENT SPOKESPERSON BACK
WITH US TONIGHT AND JOSH
KRAUSHAAR SENIOR CORRESPONDENT.
JOSH, GOOD EVENING TO YOU AS
WELL.
HUGH, KICK IT OFF.
WHAT ARE WE AND WHAT IS THIS
PRESIDENT IN FOR IN THE MONTH
AND POTENTIALLY YEARS TO COME?
>> WELL, ANYONE WHO IS UNDER THE
AGE OF 62, WHICH INCLUDES
EVERYBODY BUT ME ON THIS PANEL,
BILL, DO NOT REMEMBER WHAT THIS
IS LIKE.
WHEN I GOT OUT OF COLLEGE IN
1978, INFLATION WAS 7.6%.
IN 1979 IT WENT TO 11.3.
AND IN 1980 IT WENT TO 13.5.
IF YOU ARE YOUNG AND JUST GOING
INTO THE WORKFORCE OR YOU ARE
OLD AND ON A FIXED INCOME,
INFLATION DESTROYS YOUR ABILITY
TO MAKE A LIVING.
AND WHAT IT ALSO DOES IS DESTROY
A PRESIDENT OR PARTY AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO GET WIPED
OUT.
IT TAKES A REAGAN.
IT TAKES A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
TO CUT SPENDING, CUT TAXES AND
THE STATES AND FEDERAL LEVEL
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE
GOING THROUGH SOMETHING THEY
HAVE NEVER GONE THROUGH BEFORE.
FOLKS ON SOCIAL SECURITY GOT A
5.6% COLA, THAT'S ALREADY GONE.
AND THE MILITARY PAY RAISE AND
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR 4.6%.
WE ALREADY HEARD 9.1% YEAR OVER
YEAR IT'S A DISASTER FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> Bill: THAT'S TOUGH.
ONE MAN WHO WAS THERE IN THE
COCKPIT WAS ART LAFFER IN THE
EARLY 1980s HE SAW IT
FIRSTHAND A BIT EARLIER TODAY HE
HAD THIS FORECAST, WATCH.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THESE
NUMBERS GO UP AND UP AND UP.
IT'S ACCELERATING AND THIS THING
IS OUT OF CONTROL.
THIS IS ABOUT AS BAD AS IT GETS.
AND COMBINED WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS, WHICH ARE NOT GOOD FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION, I DON'T SEE
HOW THEY PULL OUT OF A CRASH.
>> MORGAN, DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR THAT?
>> NO, I WISH I DID.
I MEAN, LISTEN, THIS FEELS VERY
MUCH LIKE 2008, THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS.
AND THERE WAS SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THAT TIME WHOSE
CAREERS REALLY -- WE ARE STILL
SEEING THE EFFECTS OF THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS IN TERMS OF
MILLENNIALS NOT BUYING HOMES
STILL HAVING STUDENT DEBT.
I THINK THIS ECONOMY MAY BE ON
TRACK TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF
RAMIFICATION FOR OLDER PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T RETIRE.
FOR YOUNGER PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SAVE AND
LEAVE HOME AND BUY THEIR OWN
HOME.
THE ADMINISTRATION, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS EXPERIENCING
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
TO EXPERIENCE IN WASHINGTON.
AND THAT'S WHEN THE REALITY OF
YOUR POLICY, COME TO FRUITION
AND THEY FAILED, IT'S HARD TO
ADMIT THAT THEY ARE NOT WORKING.
RIGHT?
IT'S HARD TO ADMIT THAT MAYBE IT
WAS A MISTAKE SPENDING
$2 TRILLION.
AND, LOOK NO FURTHER, BY THE
WAY, WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO
HURT THE MOST IN NOVEMBER WILL
BE WITH MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
YOU HAVE 29% OF HISPANIC
AMERICANS APPROVING OF BIDEN'S
JOB PERFORMANCE.
49% OF BLACK AMERICANS.
GIVE DEVASTATING NUMBERS FOR ANY
DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET
BETTER ANY TIME SOON BECAUSE
THEY REFUSE SENATOR JOE MANCHIN.
HE PUT OUT A STATEMENT QUICKLY
PART OF IT READ LIKE THIS.
NO MATTER WHAT SPENDING
ASPIRATIONS SOME IN CONGRESS MAY
HAVE.
IT'S CLEAR TO ANYONE WHO VISITS
A GROCERY STORE OR GRASS STATION
THAT WE CANNOT ADD ANY MORE FUEL
TO THIS INFLATION FIRE.
CAN YOU GAUGE THE IMPACT ON AN
ELECTION 11 DAYS FROM NOW.
>> DON'T EXPECT JOE MANCHIN TO
SUPPORT ANY NEW SPENDING AS MUCH
AS DEMOCRATS MAY WANT HIM TO.
THIS IS -- HUGH HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS DEGREE OF INFLATION SINCE
THE JIMMY CARTER ADMINISTRATION
AND WE KNOW HOW THAT ENDED UP IN
THE 70S.
AND, LOOK, A POLITICAL HEAD WIND
FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION.
I'M A LITTLE PERPLEXED TOO,
BILL, THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T REALLY ACKNOWLEDGED THE
DEGREE OF INFLATION.
THEY WERE SPINNING TODAY THAT
GAS PRICES ARE GOING DOWN A
LITTLE BIT AND THE REPORT DIDN'T
REFLECT THAT DYNAMIC, BUT EVERY
OTHER GOOD, FOOD, GAS, ENERGY,
YOU NAME IT, THE CORE INFLATION
RATE WAS THROUGH THE ROOF, AND
WHEN YOU CAN'T ACKNOWLEDGE
REALITY, WHEN YOU HAVE TROUBLE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE CHALLENGE
IN THE FIRST PLACE, IT'S HARD TO
SPIN IT IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION
AND HAVE A PLAN TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
>> Bill: PROBABLY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
TWO MINUTES AROUND THE HORN
QUICKLY.
HUGH, WHAT IS TO BE EXPECTED
FROM THIS TRIP IN THE MIDDLE
EAST?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
REASSURE ALLIES WHO A YEAR AFTER
THE AFGHANISTAN DEBACLE DO NOT
TRUST THE AMERICAN PROMISES
BEING MADE.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO DOUBLE
DOWN AND TRIPLE DOWN ON THOSE
PROMISES BECAUSE MEMORY US OF
PEOPLE FALLING FROM PLANES ARE
STILL FRESH.
>> Bill: WHAT A MOMENT.
MORGAN THIS WAS YOUR DEPARTMENT.
WHAT COMES FROM.
>>
>> 17 MONTHS AS IT RELATES
ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
THEY REJECTED EVERY SINGLE
POLICY THAT WE PUT IN PLACE.
FIRST IN 2 # YEARS.
AND THEY HAVE FAILED.
THEY GOT PLAYED BY THE IRANIANS,
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
INTENTION OF GOING INTO THE
JCPOA.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN FIX IT ON
THE THIS TRIP.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN START TO
COURSE CORRECT.
>> Bill: JOSH?
>> GOAL NUMBER ONE WORK WITH THE
SAUDIS AND ISRAELIS TO CONTAIN
THE.
THE JCPOA IS DEAD.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE ANOTHER
NUCLEAR DEAL.
HELP CONSTRAIN NUCLEAR AMBITIONS
NUMBER TWO GETTING THE OIL
SUPPLY FROM THE SAUDIS BACK AND
IN OUR FAVOR AND START TO WORK
DIPLOMATICALLY WITH THEM AGAIN.
IT'S KIND OF STRIKING BUT THEY
ARE WORKING WITH RUSSIA AND I
THINK THE UNITED STATES WOULD
LIKE THEM TO BE BACK IN OUR
CORNER EVEN THOUGH IT'S A VERY
DELICATE DANCE.
>> Bill: THAT SAUDI OIL THING IS
NO GUARANTEE ON THIS TRIP,
RIGHT?
>> NO GUARANTEE AND THE SAUDIS
HAVE BEEN MOVING AWAY FROM THE
AMERICAN ORBIT GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE HAD SINCE THE
KHASHOGGI SITUATION.
>> Bill: WE WILL PICK IT AGAIN
TOMORROW AS THAT TRIP CONTINUES.